the entire Foundation was in turmoil
researchers were getting into heated
fist fights with security officers who
in turn were retaliating in fits of
unbridled animalistic rage the facility
had erupted into such a frenzy with
chairs being hurled across testing
Chambers and armories rated for weapons
to escalate the brawl into a far
deadlier incident tables were overturned
and used as cover as the foundation's
own staff turned on each other and
before long and all-out War had erupted
but this wasn't a battle of one side
versus another no this was a wild and
ramp and free-for-all everyone was out
to get everyone else viewing their own
colleagues as mortal enemies and it was
all thanks to Junior the spawn of the
shy guy only a month before the
foundation had been subject to another
bout of chaos although this one was much
more subdued than the explosive battle
that would later sweep the facility
everyone was a buzz researchers ignored
their work and some security Personnel
even abandon their posts to see what all
the fuss was about something was very
wrong with
scp-096 the creature was normally docile
unless directly observed it spent the
majority of its time just pacing around
in its containment chamber or staying
hunched over in a fetal position crying
to itself in fact it was so often
sobbing quietly and making all manner of
discontented noises that this became
known as its usual Behavior at first
almost nobody had noticed that something
was even amiss it all seemed right with
the miserable monster that is until the
screaming started it was a loud
shrieking sound that pierced the
eardrums of whoever heard it then
proceeded to climb down their spine and
bring a chill to their bones making
their blood run icy cold and causing
their skin to be littered with
Goosebumps the screeching disturbing
noise flooded out of scp-096's cell
reverberating off of every wall and
echoing down every Corridor until not
one member of foundation Personnel could
ignore it it was unlike anything they'd
ever heard from the creature before this
Primal howling seemed to put everyone
who Heard It On The Edge not just
because it was unfamiliar but because
everyone unkinnily seemed to know what
the screams were indicating pain perhaps
even the worst physical pain that
scp-096 had ever felt what if the shy
guy was dying something had to be done
but therein lay a hurdle to clear first
how could the foundation help even offer
medical assistance if needed to a
creature they couldn't even safely look
at what options are there for even
getting somebody close enough to examine
the shy guy without it killing them they
were limited but a crowd of the SCP
foundation's best and brightest
researchers had already congregated
outside the containment chamber
housing096 after they heard its screams
surely between them they could come up
with an idea hearing the shy guy
continuing Hal and Agony one researcher
came forward and made a suggestion there
was a device another Foundation
researcher had developed codenamed
scramble resembling standard issue night
vision goggles one Dr Dan had created
these scramble goggles to identify 096's
face and digitally alter it so that the
wearer was unable to see its face
essentially it edited out the shy guy's
face in real time so that its homicidal
rage State couldn't be activated the use
of Dr Dan's scramble goggles had
previously led to a catastrophic
incident that claimed the lives of
mobile task force Tau 1 also known as
Big Brother The Scrambled devices
allowed the wearer's brain to receive a
single nanosecond of scp-096 unscrambled
before the image was altered by the
goggles so needless to say since time
was running out to help the creature and
there were no other viable options for
doing so the scramble goggles would need
some serious refinement and fast working
as quickly as they could it they
gathered gaggle of researchers
requisitioned an old pair of scrambled
goggles and started trying to improve
them tinkering equipment Specialists put
their heads together with computer
science Engineers as they coded like
crazy all underscored by the continued
screams of scp-096 then without warning
or even a hint of what had happened
inside the cell the screaming suddenly
stopped everyone outside the containment
chamber stopped for a second falling
deathly silent the goggles were almost
ready but were they too late to save the
shy guy the security Personnel who had
also gathered in response to the sound
all Drew straws with the officer pulling
the shortest being the one tasked with
venturing into the containment chamber
it was handed the goggles and instructed
that they would blur his version
entirely for a few seconds while the
scramble software had a chance to work
then once the device had doubled triple
and quadruple checked the results the
goggles would activate fully and in
theory work the way Dr Dan had
originally intended although the track
record of the scramble project meant
that the officer was hardly reassured as
he entered the dark dingy containment
chamber he couldn't see a thing ahead of
him his vision totally obscured as the
goggles started running the newly
updated version of the scramble software
they were untested so naturally the
security officer's nerves were at Peak
levels worried the device might fail and
any second his eyes would be greeted by
the face of
scp-096 he could tell the creature was
still alive there was a low sound of
panting breaths coming from the far
corner of the chamber indicating that it
hadn't perished although it might have
been injured a sudden beep from the
scramble goggles startled the officer
the device had made its tracks and was
ready to activate however an unexpected
message blinked on the heads-up display
that read warning multiple subjects
detected luckily enough when the goggles
activated the officer was relieved to
see they had worked
scp-096's face was a grainy pixelated
mess the creatures showed little
noticeable sign of any injuries too and
just seemed to be gently rocking itself
in the corner but quickly the reason and
perhaps even the cause of scp-096's
earlier scream soon became obvious
though nobody had entered the
containment cell before the security
officer it seemed the shy guy wasn't
alone standing at about a third of
scp-096's considerable height was
another shy guy or at least another
version of a creature almost identical
saved for being shorter it wobbled on
its elongated legs like it wasn't quite
used to standing upright it kept both
arms outstretched towards scp-096 almost
as though it was reaching out for a hug
but the shy guy stayed in the corner
cowering away from the other creature
through his scramble goggles the
security officer looked on in disbelief
at the scene before him somehow
completely unpredictably
scp-096 had spawned an offspring it had
had a baby there was a general error of
disbelief among the assembled staff
outside the containment chamber after
the security officer had relayed what
had happened most were quick to write it
off as an impossibility they'd studied
scp-096 for a long time and it had been
the only anomaly known to the foundation
matching its own very particular
description there had been no others
cited in the wild it didn't seem to be
part of a species as far as anyone knew
but other researchers refuted this claim
given as cp096's ability to travel at
anomalous speeds and kill those that
looked at it it stood to reason there
could be others maybe the foundation
wasn't aware of a whole species of shy
guys because anyone who'd ever seen one
didn't live long enough to report it
then someone mentioned that it wasn't
entirely unprecedented for anomalies to
have Offspring either a long while
before as cp049 the infamous beak Mass
plague doctor had laid an egg which had
hatched into scp-049 Dash j a smaller
version of himself composed of moss and
wads of tissue trying to apply logical
understanding to each and every anomaly
was a paradoxical exercise in futility
all anomalies had their own rules even
rules the foundation had never observed
before after a great deal of
deliberation and additional improvements
of the scramble technology a research
team was sent into the containment
chamber to retrieve
scp-096's progeny the parent creature
was still shying away from its creation
perhaps because it didn't want to raise
it in the way that meant the child
inherited its deadly sense of
self-consciousness then again maybe the
shy guy was just afraid of what it had
Unleashed on an unsuspecting Foundation
initial testing with The Offspring
creature revealed it was perfectly
healthy and seemingly very much unlike
its predecessor until any official SCP
Foundation designation number could be
assigned the team examining it took to
calling it scp-096
junior or shortened to Simply junior
junior regarded the foundation
scientists with curiosity intrigued by
them as well as their surroundings
picking up medical instruments before
very carefully placing them back where
it found them treating every item it
touched like they had been made of the
finest most delicate glass one of the
researchers likened its movements to
that of a lemur or other similar
primates but with the reserved timid and
docile nature of a well-domesticated pet
but was at first naturally the SCP
Foundation being the organization that
it is that quickly became an interest in
whether Junior displayed the same
anomalous traits as
scp-096 call it curiosity or caution
they wanted to know if it would react
the same way when observed without the
protection of scramble goggles so a test
was devised seating a member of d-class
Personnel in the same room as Junior and
tasked only with looking at the Shy
Guy's spawn everyone gathered with
baited breath the research team watching
from an observation desk all of them
wearing scramble goggles to blur Jr's
face as a blindfolded d-class was
brought in and stood opposite of Junior
all of them expected that the test would
unfold in a particular way which made it
all the more surprising when as the
d-class's blindfold was removed nothing
happened Junior regarded the convict
with the same general curiosity as it
had for everyone else but beyond that
showed no change in Behavior no wild
crying no murderous rage State nothing
are we sure this is actually the Shy
Guy's kid one of the researchers joked
with the test concluded and then
repeated a few extra times for good
measure Junior was deemed a safe class
anomaly much like scp-999 or Josie the
half cat it was decided that Junior be
allowed to wander freely around the
facility while initially a little
unnerving to some staff when they first
saw him without goggles people quickly
warmed to Junior he was like a small
monkey from a Safari Park although with
the added benefit of not stealing
anyone's iPhone or wallet but at least
until shortly after around nearly a
month had passed since Junior's birth
and since then an odd change had been
noted in scp-096 the shy guys seemed
calmer more at ease and far less anxious
what's more researchers discovered that
for the first time ever he could be
observed however before they could
investigate further all hell broke loose
it started in the holding cells where
d-classes were housed initially written
off as fights between inmates that got a
little too out of hand but soon the
foundation's own Personnel started to
violently attack each other it was
sparked at random a state of animalistic
rage that was focused on their fellow
staff members the people they worked
with the people who saw them every day
and it didn't stop those working at the
facility were seemingly possessed by an
inescapable urge to harm those around
them as if punishing each other for just
looking at them by the time a mobile
task force was ordered to step in and
Defuse The Situation the scene they
arrived to was one of uttered chaos
further examination uncovered that those
who had seen Junior's face had been
exposed to an anomalous effect looking
at the creature gave the Observer the
same rageful reaction to being observed
as scp-096 they were compelled to kill
anyone who saw them however most
insidiously this didn't seem to take
effect instantly in fact those affected
only entered their Collective rage state
after everyone in the facility had
interacted with Junior at least once
almost like it had been waiting to
infect everyone while the remainder of
the foundation mopped up the aftermath
of the incident some theorized that
scp-096 had somehow expelled all its
self-consciousness all of its negative
traits into its progeny this was
supposedly why the shy guy seemed so
much calmer so much so that it could
even be observed whether Junior simply
couldn't contain all scp-096's
negativity or intentionally spread it to
everyone else around it it is unknown
the only solution to get things back to
normal was to put the Shy Guy's
self-consciousness back to where it came
from now go check out scp-096 versus
scp-343 and scp-096 versus scp-106 for
more